when it comes to action movies 2021 has
been going pretty well so far out of all
those theatrical releases and streaming
debuts however it's hard to know which
are the cream of the crop have no fear
though these are the best action movies
of 2021 so far
in march 2021 after much demand from the
franchise's fans dc and warner brothers
released director zack snyder's original
vision for the justice league's first
live-action film following the 2017
release of joss whedon's much derided
franken movie no one knew quite what to
expect from this new take on snyder's
original vision but the end results are
strong featuring more fleshed out story
arcs for each member of the team and a
villain with more relatable motivations
but zack snyder's justice league truly
delivers with its action scenes to die
hard snyder fans the director's talent
for action will come as no surprise for
anybody who hadn't yet experienced his
particular brand of artfully framed
gleefully ridiculous action however
justice league is a superb demonstration
of what he does best
the setup for godzilla vs kong is simple
godzilla attacks humanity unprovoked so
the humans call upon kong to lead them
to a source of energy that can defeat
him during the journey the terror of
tokyo crosses paths with the eighth
wonder of the world and they throw down
to see who gets to be king of monsters
while the movie received mixed reviews
on release critics have largely praised
its kong on zilla action director adam
wingard's previous movies your next and
the guest married a number of genres
with some seriously effective action
scenes and wingard's greatest success in
godzilla vs kong is his keen ability to
plot out those fight scenes and make
every punch bite and nuclear breath
blast count and sure the critics have
taken issue with godzilla vs kong's
plotting and character development but
that's not really the point of this
movie is it as wise man once said
let them fight
watching an action movie can sometimes
feel like visiting a familiar diner you
know the menu you know what you like and
you know what not to order so when a
movie like nobody comes along any fan of
the genre knows they're in for a very
specific viewing experience produced by
one half of the john wick brain trust
david leach and starring funny man bob
odenkirk nobody nonetheless proved to be
certifiably awesome this movie brings
such relish to what it is attempting
from the performances to the fight
choreography to the plot itself that it
easily stands out in the long line of
action thriller franchises that came
before it most of that success is due to
odenkirk himself who in a stroke of
genius plays hutch manziel like a
recovering addict one who has gleefully
broken a long cold turkey run of
non-violence throw in a wonderful
supporting cast and some deft direction
from ilya neishaler and you've got one
of those rare movies that truly
transcends the tried and tested formula
world war ii is having a bit of a genre
moment right now and movies blending
extreme war violence with sci-fi horror
action have become a cottage industry
think 2018's overlord or the outpost
franchise what makes shadow and the
cloud unique to this niche category
however is its perspective and focus on
the women in the war effort shadow tells
the story of chloe grace moretz's flight
officer mod garrett and the secret
mission that has her hitching a ride on
a b-52 bomber in the midst of japanese
occupied airspace the first half of the
movie basically confines moretz to the
bottom turret of the plane her isolation
is in one of the worst places to be in
an aircraft outside and underneath it
pair that with the sexist verbal abuse
she receives from the male crew over the
radio and the movie builds a highly
specific brand of suspense not often
seen on the silver screen but things
really get crazy when spoiler heavy
details reveal themselves allowing the
movie to dive into some b-movie action
that wouldn't feel out of place in an
empty movie theater in the 1980s if you
haven't already give this one a shot
it's as silly as anything and well worth
a watch
the fast and the furious movies aren't
about car chases they aren't about wild
stunts either or muscled up dudes
punching each other okay so maybe
they're about those things a little but
at the end of the day this franchise is
all about one thing
i don't have friends i got family that's
especially true in f9 in which
everybody's favorite street racer
dominic toretto butts heads with his
estranged brother jacob obviously the
result is a whole bunch of car chases
wild stunts and muscled up dudes
punching each other luckily f9 is also
one of the best installments in a truly
wild and incredible franchise it hails
the return of justin lin the director
who reinvigorated the series with tokyo
drift and created a new direction for
the franchise with parts 4 5 and 6. here
the filmmaker expertly blends the
melodrama with the spectacle giving long
time fans of the franchise everything
they want and more if you're looking for
a fun fast-paced and heartfelt time at
the movies f9 is the perfect action film
for you
cinematically speaking 2021 has been a
fantastic year for zack snyder in
addition to wowing critics and fans
alike with his unadulterated take on
justice league the man gave dave
bautista a machine gun sent him to sin
city and had him shoot down a whole
bunch of zombies talk about peak action
cinema army of the dead takes place in a
world where a zombie uprising has been
confined to las vegas the undead shovel
past slot machines poker tables and a
vault filled with 200 million dollars
and so zombie killing veteran scott ward
is hired to assemble a team of
mercenaries to make their way into vegas
and retrieve the cash if they succeed
it's the ultimate jackpot if not well
you know things get complicated when it
turns out the government plans on nuking
vegas off the face of the earth things
get even more complicated when scott's
estranged daughter tags along and things
get even more complicated when the
zombies reveal themselves to be far more
than your ordinary ghouls army of the
dead it's silly it's loud it's gory what
more could you possibly want
it took way too long for natasha romanov
to get her own movie but now that black
widow is here it turns out the final
result was definitely worth the wait
this marvel action flick works as a
prequel picking up right after the
airport battle in captain america's
civil war after betraying team tony and
letting steve rogers escape natasha is
on the run trying to lay low and figure
out her new post avengers life but when
the super spy crosses paths with her
adoptive sister yelena bulova she
realizes it's time to take care of some
unfinished business before long she is
reunited with her old adoptive family to
take down some villains and blow some
stuff up you know the usual more than
anything though black widow is about
what it means to come from a fractured
family and it's also a surprisingly
thoughtful look at guilt as natasha is
still struggling to wipe all that red
from her ledger in addition to those
engaging themes and some impressive
action scenes johansson gives a
fantastic performance bolstered by a
hilariously goofy david harbour and a
charmingly snarky pew it's a sad
farewell to natasha herself but at least
marvel has sent her off in style
let's be honest the original suicide
squad wasn't great so that's it
what was some kind of
suicide squad
it has a lousy 26 critical score over on
rotten tomatoes and even the audience
score is a lackluster 59
the lowest in the dc eu so far so why is
the sequel any different in a sentence
it's all down to the magic james gun the
director who made everyone fall in love
with a talking raccoon and a dancing
tree was the perfect guy to shepherd
this ragtag band of anti-heroes to
success and sure enough with the suicide
squad gunn injects the dc universe with
a heavy dose of quippy crazy gory fun of
course gunn hasn't totally forgotten
about the original film as he's brought
over some of the best characters from
the first installment but he also brings
in a whole new rogues gallery none of
whom are guaranteed to make it even to
the movie's halfway point as for the
plot the titular squad is sent down to a
south american island to stop a
nefarious game called project starfish
and yes that's exactly what it sounds
like by the time it's all said and done
gun has offered up a dirty dozen style
war movie with plenty of gags plenty of
guts and a near-perfect rotten tomato
score the only lingering question when's
part 3
when you think about legendary action
stars there are any number of names that
might jump to mind but what about karen
gillen she's nebula in the marvel
cinematic universe ruby roundhouse in
the jumanji franchise and famously cut
her teeth in the world of doctor who but
with gunpowder milkshake gillen truly
proves her action star bonafides this
action thriller finds gillen playing sam
an assassin working for a mysterious
organization called the firm but when a
dangerous mission goes south sam decides
to turn on the firm and protect an
eight-year-old girl drawing the wrath of
her employers if you love the world
building of the john wick franchise then
gunpowder milkshake will be right up
your alley it also features some of the
craziest action scenes you'll see all
year and shines the spotlight on the
ladies too with women supporting women
as they batter down bad guys and mow
down hitmen filled to the brim with neon
visuals and madcap violence gunpowder
milkshake is a genuine treat for the
senses
it's a tale as old as time or at least
as old as 1993. somebody finds
themselves trapped in the same day and
no matter what happens they wake right
back up on the very same morning and
repeat the same 24 hours all over again
groundhog day properly kicked off the
time loop genre but a number of movies
have played with the concept over the
years none though were quite so
action-packed as boss level starring the
world's most underrated action star
frank grillo boss level finds roy pulver
stuck in a particularly painful time
loop every day he gets killed no matter
what he does he wakes up and then at
some point or another he wounds up dead
naturally this doesn't sit well with mr
pulver and he sets out to crack some
skulls evade his imminent death and
figure out how he got trapped in this
crazy day with some solid direction by
joe carnahan and a great villainous turn
from mel gibson boss level is a fun spin
on a familiar premise
who are the greatest actor director
combos of all time well you've got akira
kurosawa and toshiro mifune of course
and john ford and john wayne or maybe
you'd say martin scorsese and robert de
niro and sure they're all great but
tashiro mifune never had a gunfight with
post malone did he enter guy richie and
jason statham from snatch to lock stock
these two action icons have made some of
the craziest most intense movies of all
time and in 2021 they treated us to
wrath of men the movie stars stay at him
as patrick hill a security guard who
keeps crooks from knocking off armored
trucks he's the new guy on the job but
he's surprisingly good at it a little
too good in fact naturally hill's
co-workers begin to suspect there's more
to this rookie than meets the eye and
soon enough it's revealed that something
sinister is going on forget the plot
though wrath of man is most importantly
filled with gunfire and explosions and
features stay them at his action star
best here and sometimes that's all you
need
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]